We Begin this NewsHour with breaking
news from Sudan after nearly two days of
fighting between the Army and the
powerful paramilitary rapid support
forces or rsf the UN says a temporary
pause in fighting has been agreed on
humanitarian grounds
Sudan has seen a bitter power struggle
since Saturday when the airstrikes and
gun battles began
this has been the state of play this is
where things stand at the moment
fighting began spreading across the
country the worst of the violence
however has been centered on the capital
Khartoum and on neighboring doorman both
sides have been vying for control of
Sudan's State broadcaster of the
presidential Palace and the airport as
well as multiple military bases
the Army has now agreed to a safe
passage Corridor for Urgent humanitarian
cases however Aid workers are also at
risk in all of this the un's world food
program says three of its employees have
been killed
the wfp's executive director has
released a statement saying while we
review the evolving security situation
we are forced to temporarily halt all
operations in Sudan
wfp is committed to assisting the
Sudanese people facing dire food
insecurity but we cannot do our
life-saving work if the Safety and
Security of our teams and partners is
not guaranteed
all right let's go straight to Hibbett
Morgan in cartoon hey but what can you
tell us about this pause in the fighting
has it begun and is it holding
well as per both sides the Sudanese Army
and the rapid support forces it's a
period of three hours where those who
are in need and let's focus on that
those who are in need would be able to
get out of their homes and out of this
out of Hartung City to be able to access
facilities such as uh hospitals and
health centers so it looks like it's
very targeted with regard with regards
to who can actually get on board on that
humanitarian Corridor it's not been
specified as exactly where those
corridors would be open and both sides
said that they do reserve the right to
defend themselves should they feel that
they're under attack so it doesn't look
like it's something that uh that that
would hold or would give civilians at
least some kind of assurance that they
would be able to venture out in the
streets lots of concerns here but
there's also a bit of movement on the
streets of Khartoum many people who were
trapped here in harsum City when the
fighting broke out in the early hours of
Saturday morning are now taking this
time to get out of the facilities they
were trapped items such as hospitals and
schools around the vicinity of the
presidential Palace and the general
command of the army and trying to make
their way to safety during this
three-hour period that was granted by
both the rapid support forces and the
Army after facilitation and mediation by
the UN so Herbert just to be clear who
is this aimed at it's civilians who live
in or near the fighting is that right
it's aimed at the civilians who were
trapped in areas of fighting places like
schools around the vicinity of the
presidential Palace around the vicinity
of the general command hospitals where
people could not seek treatment or
hospitals where people went for renal
dialysis for example there have been
people who were trapped in such health
facilities and Medics have been calling
on both sides the rsf and the Army to
open such corridors so these are the
people that those corridors are directed
for again it's not specified which
routes they can take where they can head
to but the Urgent uh issue here or the
important matter here is that they
should leave the vicinity of the
fighting areas areas such as the
presidential Palace areas such as the
general command of the Army Headquarters
and areas where their basis of the rapid
support forces which have been facing
airstrikes since the early hours of
Sunday morning hibber Morgan reporting
live from cartoon thank you very much
now let's speak to he's the founding
director at Confluence advisory that's a
think tank based in cartoon she joins us
from Khartoum right now holud first of
all your reaction to this three-hour
pause in the fighting to allow civilians
to get out of the most dangerous areas
I think it's a positive sign that at
least the generals can come to some kind
of arrangements but as we speak
um the time frame is meant to be from 4
to 7 pm and as we speak I can hear
shelling and not so far from my house
and both light and heavy artillery
um in the background so clearly
um one of two things either the general
misled the U.N which wouldn't be the
first time or they don't have as much
control of their troops as one would
hope
okay that's really interesting because
the uh this this temporary this
three-hour pause in the fighting is from
four to seven local time and it's
currently 5 p.m local where you are
you're reporting that there is still
shelling going on so
we we know that the pause in the
fighting isn't completely holding uh and
you mentioned perhaps control of the
troops is an issue
development
yes absolutely I have heard from friends
around the city that they have been able
to move around to some degree and that
some shops are open to allow people to
restock but of course there are broader
problems for example people who are
Income independent
um are not able to get access to
incident because pharmacies have run out
partly because uh the uh airports are
closed of course because of the piping
so there are Ripple effects
um to the broader conflict that cannot
be ameliorated by this uh three-hour
window do you feel safe going out of
your house right now being in the street
in cartoon
well considering what I can hear outside
of my Windows though not at all
a great many people will feel that
certainly on social media lots of people
have been saying that they don't feel
safe enough uh to leave their home but I
think part of the results are that many
people don't trust
the general the the abide by this and
the srsd the special representative of
the Secretary General Focus that is in
his statement about to see um this sort
of temporary safety corridor said that
this is sort of a gentleman of agreement
it's based on trust of both my other
side
um is sort of
um beyond their word has given any kind
of indications of fixed by this as we
already know that these generals do not
keep to their work so I think that lack
of mistrust me that many people don't
feel safe to leave their homes
where do you see this going
well the advantages
we'll just be the case that they are
willing to sort of sit down and end this
in any kind of permanent way I think
they at least have been
um using sort of um more propaganda if
you will to try and frame their actions
as firstly in self-defense and secondly
in defense of the new democracy and so
you know agreeing to a temporary uh sort
of a piece by in order to Avail safety
corridors pulled into
um those ploys to get to frame their
actions as in sort of the humanitarian
and Democratic way but I don't think
that will carry much favor or indeed get
much traction with many of the needs
with our citizens who have had to live
through the past 36 to 48 hours in an
anxiety and fear
director at Confluence advisory in
cartoon thank you so much for joining us
more now from middleway in the north of
the country
we've been hearing gunfire of both light
and heavy weapons which was likely to
Signal renewed fighting here within the
vicinity of marawi airport soon it all
came to Halt and what remains is the
plumes of smoke from the vital
installations within the facility close
to its control tower as you can see this
is the aftermath of the fighting that
began a short while ago the rapid
support forces had said they had seized
control of the marawa airport claims
denied by senior sources we contacted in
the Sudanese Army here in the northern
Province they confirmed the airport is
under the Army's control as the armed
forces deal with what they're calling
small pockets of rebels an apparent
reference to the rapid support forces